maintenant est ce qu'on peut bien parler
excusez moi alors est ce qu'on peut bien
parler une langue sens quand on ne
l'écrit pas bien notre en soit je crois
pas bien entendu si peu bien là parler
bien entendu quand on n'a pas vu les
mots écrits et quelles raisons au
contraire au contraire l'écriture peut
être un obstacle puisque écriture
souvent voix hier soir française que les
enfants autant de mal à apprendre
s'éloigne de la prononciation
par conséquent les canucks et vous qui
connaissez tellement de langues ces
lettrés mieux quand on commence à
apprendre une langue il faut apprendre
le derme
si on n'a pas des points de repère très
vite la langue sa funeste du one man one
vote
il faut l'avoir vu quand même il faut
l'avoir vu écrit ça
what do you want what do you - écoutez
monsieur devos un de vos sketches à
montparnasse gascon bâti en septembre 82
vous avez imiter le japonais vous
souvenez vous cependant votre imitation
était remarquable c'était une foyers
japonais ce qui existe et est où
mais c'est ça a existé oui vous n'avez
pas lu écrite et pourtant vous limitiez
il est un grand admirateur de doses je
suis un spectateur admiratif oui j'aime
cette façon de se prendre la langue dans
des toiles d'araignée des mots j'aime
qu'ils soient ce qui l'est c'est un
prince un prince de l'absurde mais un
prince en vivres pour écouter vraiment
tous les
si vous aimez
je dois vous dire j'ai pris un plaisir
je ne sais pas parce que souhaite pas
pour vous rendre la monnaie
mais c'est parce que votre livre un
livre extraordinaire en fait d'un livre
de chevet pour les chantiers annoncés
juste eu quelques difficultés
je suis des choses qui vous je suis
certes quand je suis fatigué j'ai noté
qu'il est sincère car il est un prince
de la syntaxe est il un homme de langage
par conséquent à nu sur le langage même
je reconnais un peu difficile par
moments a peut-être des titrailles
peut-être pas un livre de chevet mais à
lyss be
le concerne 2 je peux pas me dire le
plaisir je peux que j'ai pris à virale
et je n'ai pas lu entièrement c'est pas
possible elle remue mais c'est fabuleux
c'est de la poussée de la grande poésie
bon dernier